what'd you learn about life from your
dad
and my dad got girls too but those are
the small details that's a big detail
being that I found my dad's you know
Playboy when I was five years old it it
greatly affected my motivation
yeah all right so that's part of the
engine that drives yay absolutely I
remember when Pharrell was first in all
the videos
and my girl was like uh girls like
Pharrell and I was like I want girls to
like me too funny that that's behind all
the ambition all the drive that's how we
make people
that's how people are made
it's the desire to be loved
is that
at the individual level just being
noticed and also at the societal level
at scale well now
I've I've gone past I'm like at that
place
where Nikolai Tesla was uh
uh later into his career where it wasn't
about being loved it wasn't about
sitting at the dinner parties next to
Anna Wintour and stuff it was about
getting the idea across
so I have these
cells
that are very and I just keep on saying
really Scott but really Scott has a
special
anointing it isn't just sci-fi what he's
doing
there's something in there just like
George Lucas
there's something different that's there
so
what are you drawing I'm drawing these
new living cells that we will exist in
and this is over
okay let's do like
I don't like talking about money because
like man make money anyways like four
quadrillion
respected dollars and then you have
other forms of currency of course social
currency is super important right now
but this is a drawing
and it's at a pretty good place
now this will be forty thousand square
feet I want to start just talking to
meters I just think we should go to
anything to restore the Tower of Basil
like they said when the uh
I'll just draw a person here for scale
uh yeah that would help
okay
what do you think of that look at my
person see the scale in this room
all right so
wait the dot is the person yeah
I'm saying it's 40 000 square feet
but that would be like what are the
other parts of the cell
okay so what it's a screen it doesn't go
all the all the way to the top and it's
one hole for light but the water and the
light and air all come in from the top
so that's like
like the mouth and then this is the
belly button where God's iPhone where
his greatest creation
so this is all connected these are all
connected yes I'm drawing how these
other cells go next to each other what's
the vision here
happiness then we talk about like what's
the motivation like yeah there's a
motivation somewhere in the back of my
mind
of
my family
and
if it's like where Moses Smite The Rock
and God didn't allow him
to
get to the promised land because the
promised land is family that is the
problem that is
Earth I mean that is heaven on Earth is
family family is heaven that's the
promised land and for your family to be
together
uh so say I smite The Rock and God
doesn't let me
have my family back my mission and life
is still to
promote families
at all costs and make families existence
easier so you take this thing you put
localize
a localized Farm see if it's in
community that we we do localized
growing and then we partner with big
Pharma and all and say hey you're
actually going to make more money
by making better food
because at the end of the day you want
money right now it's like everyone knows
that between the pesticides and between
the medical industry and especially
America that we're keeping people sick
and we know that McDonald's makes food
that kills people and you know Coca-Cola
is selling you know sugar water and all
this like
just in case I haven't pissed off enough
people in power yeah okay so you're
gonna piss off the shirt anybody that's
powered on Sugar Sugar well sugar what's
the health was actually a document
documentary on sugar it wasn't about how
bad meat was it was like a reverse
documentary on sugar a refer I don't
know if you call it reverse like a sub
but if you watch it again when they show
sugar and it's just the sugar looks
super clean
yeah so as I State as I State these
things
I know that
I know I have protection
if I have God's protection that's why
I'm here to this date right so it it's
for me to have this platform and express
exactly what I feel because it's kids
out there right that
um it's kids that are gonna save the
world through engineering and through
facts
and I've got to get download as much of
the information and as much of the don't
be afraid to State your facts is the
biggest thing because the world is being
ran by fear and that is no actually God
runs the world but there's just like
little Cloud this patina of our ego
uh that deals with the money and the car
and the girl we're dating and all this
in the clothes you wear and spending too
much on clothes and a lot of stuff that
I've been involved with promoting so now
what I'm promoting is you have the idea
you say it out loud like you like if you
had Tourette's say your truth out loud
if you hate yay you hate me say that out
loud say whatever you feel
out loud like you say it
non-violently you know non-violent none
of I have to say that like guys you know
you know as a shout out to Alex Jones
you know and Trump where they try to say
that when they say their truths out loud
that it's inciting right and so let's be
like really clear I'm saying that
they have criminalized free thought the
you know they I hate when people use
they like they get to blame for
everything right it's always they yeah
who who the [ __ ] is that exactly
I promise days us yeah well I love that
what we need to do is turn I to we
so we take the responsibility and turn
they to us so we take accountability
to us
rate I to we and they to us and that
relates it's a language at the same time
you've seen the language of our
surroundings you're seeing the language
of
okay one of one of the things okay let's
go back to the cell explanation because
I'm also doing it what's that thing when
Elon just put all the information in the
open and people could figure out if they
could figure it out and open source yeah
open source.com open sourcing this idea
right now so that you know
engineers and anointed people uh beings
anointed beings can collectively
contribute to this to push our species
forward
um so where I've got to with my research
is that there will be a hole at the top
that allows natural light
natural air and there's a constant water
system so it becomes like a water city
where it's a constant flow uh that's not
it's it's regenerative it's not wasting
the water and it's just a constant flow
so I put the toilet really close to
where this
uh this
um I don't want to call it a wave pool
but in the pool the water is not still
so that exists in in water
he's surrounded by water well the living
room is that you have two rooms you have
the dry room which people will call the
living room before and then you have the
wet room
how is that a source of happiness
what is what is uh broken about our
world today that that gives you in terms
of the pursuit of happiness which is one
of the things well all of our previous
declaration all of our buildings are
based on just
the industry and the economy
and then people lean into what people
are used to seeing
like
what we think is attractive because then
you go back to
the you know women who give life so
everyone wants to be attractive
to the attractive and that's the reason
why the media
goes and gets you know Bella Hadid Kim
Kardashian
uh Emily Ratajkowski
um
those are the only ones I'm gonna uh
there's more there's more but I'm I'm
thinking the ones that I think are
attractive it is subjective yeah because
it's subjective so to my subjective
which I think I think
uh the only guys that could argue with
me on
um on my opinion on girls would be Brad
and Leo because we're the only ones with
the track record you know everything
else so for everybody else is subjective
we've got history so